um yo hello welcome to this video
plaints muckerman wow I really have one
hundred percent squads disguise yourself
let's keep it like that yeah and you
never know against him bloomed I had
five out of five and lost the last three
games I mean out of three great
positions still but yet still three
losses so what's uh come on what are you
doing here but i really go with G for
him if he allows me to do some I think
it's possible right this is the idea of
92 at least I wonder if it's good here
actually castles g4 I will do it anyway
k 25 could be something my position
looks with the 10 exposed I takes Knight
ticks ticks on e4 maybe yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I have to be an F to be on the
look out here ninth innings and then
some d5 I could could be could be crazy
to double check but he has no it has no
good check I think now it takes 90 XD
592 we has no great check them yeah this
is this is an aggressive no def five if
I just go back to e2 isn't that good
strategically yeah come on let's go back
d 5 is weak now well this is not the end
of the world still but
still it should be a little something
for what a little something that's not
blunder this work let's see it's not
mine Solomon isn't that from some books
for children soccer man i have this week
memory so add also g5 is on the agenda
let's go g5 pushing back and 95 was
trading and I don't want to trade here
so much so let's let's go here ready for
FY f is for forward okay um this was
this is some from a book actually I
don't claim copyright for that from
Portland wine is cool chest it's a nice
book if you can get it so now would a
book it's full off just interesting
chess positions games it's kind of
random a little bit but still pretty
cool so he wants to go to d for it love
to play c3 sometime yeah if I'm
mmm he might challenge with 97 here why
do I just develop he actually I mean
like Bishop b3 like that just develop a
little bit I mean I've gained so much
space now idea is 91 and then C 3 where
do you go slackline 12 g 4 right yeah
this I have to prevent that really have
to so please c 3 i'm almost trapping the
tripping the night when i'm wondering
this is some some counter sacrifice
something weigh 95 maybe I see that I
think I don't edition man just bro I had
just snatched the ball on d4 tone
twisting this is a good move young it is
what i was saying Eric I would
definitely like to have the night to
support to support down term it's not I
can't go back I don't want to wind up on
there the night has to go to d5 and then
see if really
this just keeps keeps a great initiative
coin rookie 895 people even sacrifice
now no anyway and now just see form and
then take the fall Jim I can also go see
3 i'm going to put it back there now
rookie one bishop for convenient
position i can just put some pressure
and he has very little counter play and
thing is however have to at one point
win this game just shuffling around is
not not winning me sir this game this
prevent the beep on 95 you going over to
g3 for potential Knight f6
still a huge pressure here um this going
see for you maybe yeah okay if he goes
93 this is so this is this is kind of
tricky yeah that's true 93 is a little
bit uncomfortable hmm ok I don't want to
it maybe have to do this this is giving
up on some of my advantage am quite
clearly so f 6 or not f6 time morning
take six it's not clear winning actually
if it takes it
rookie 5 is preparing this is certainly
wrong life threatening of 6mm I let him
escape there from that fantastic
position really bad play it's not
trading Queens it's tits a surprising
decision check we always get in quick
here check wow wow what's going on you
check is completely hat trick me check
I'm going to play for time you what they
would like four thirds fun time ah ah
this is totally crazy from this position
and only totally shocked me with this
with this thing that I was wow wow yeah
well this is part of the game i probably
will get again some angry comments or
something because it was the image was
just like a complete wipeout I just
probably just relish to watch this
position we can do do anything yeah it's
just so nice now I'm kind of okay with
what I did I mean I'm totally
controlling him
not not surprised up this evaluation but
I didn't do it do it as forcefully as I
could definitely not and here he got
this see foreign and this was this is
not great yeah this is not great anymore
I mean what is the engine giving just
just to show one line that will kill
like so h5 h6 is doing the trick I mean
what what kind of position is that ok
but he totally totally tricked me after
that again I mean here this is so some
control word it's not as good as it
should and then he just blinded f6 and
still a bishop here Bishop CC took here
he takes is probably better Wow and then
here and he totally that's crazy that's
crazy ok I have 11 seconds does this is
kind of making it a little bit lesson
but I mean he cannot move his bishop
even I mean I just play like what the
engine does here Queenie 3 enters over
and that I totally lost any kind of
control him now it was a closer playing
super quickly at this moment but i
blundered everypony oh that's possible
totally totally losing control check
yeah neighbors just having doing this
very well you irritating me that's so
crazy how how this fell apart so quickly
because I can easily play move like
anything like this yeah I'm just
covering everything and you cannot even
move this piece down so this should be
something that is doable even with
little time but their pride this is
mostly about moving quickly and I don't
I don't have all made him him Wow now
that I have to finish this earlier
position or for sure ok guys thanks for
watching